Police have failed to clear a major
bridge-crossing between the US and Canada.
It's being blocked by truckers
protesting against vaccine rules.
Police persuaded some drivers to move their
vehicles - but they reconvened later. The weekend
has also brought a fresh wave of protesters into
the Canadian capital, Ottawa, where a core group
of truckers continue to occupy the downtown area.
Taking their outrage to the government's doorstep.
It's been over two weeks now that the Freedom
Convoy has camped in the Canadian capital Ottawa.
A plan to force unvaccinated truck
drivers crossing between Canada and the US
to quarantine, sparked the initial rally.
But the demonstrators insist the blockade goes
beyond opposing the rules on inoculations.
We're not here about vaccinations,
and I could tell you 90 percent of the
truckers here are likely vaccinated,
but we are here for the freedom of choice.
More Canadians need to wake up and realize
that our freedoms are being stripped away. It
is not normal for us to wear masks all day. I'm
sick and tired of it. I'm a teacher. Students
in the classroom are sick and tired of it too.
Police could not move the protesters off a border
crossing. It's one of the major corridors into the
United States. The blockade has affected trade
and supply chains between the two countries.
It's also inspired support rallies over
the border to Buffalo in New York State,
and as far away as New Zealand.
In the Netherlands - truckers
rolled through The Hague.
Thousands of French police were deployed to
stop Convoy of Freedom from entering Paris,
but some protesters made it.
They took aim at Vaccine Passes
and President Emmanuel Marcon, but also
tapped into the discontent over rising prices.
Our rights, our freedoms are violated, we just
have the right to work, to spend and to be taxed.
The price of diesel increases, wheat
increases, sugar increases, insurance
increases, everything increases.
Police cleared the streets using tear
gas. But this has not ended the protests. Next
stop, the European Union's power-base in Brussels.